hey craig i had a great time playing
board games last night which reminds me
i've recently completed a top secret
side project a web app to track each
player's performance and win rates over
time
you know for bragging rights
bragging rights i love bragging
but say what did you use to build this
web app
so lately i'll be using django for my
web apps backgrounds but deploying
django isn't always easy
martin when i say i feel you on that but
luckily i've been working on a terraform
script to automate the entire process on
gcp want to test it out on your project
yeah that would be amazing show me the
way
[Music]
i've been using and deploying django for
over a decade and honestly it's tricky
every time
that makes me feel better to hear you
say that
there are a lot of tedious parts to get
right yeah there sure are uh you need a
database a web server that ideally
scales storage for static files in media
and encrypted application secrets it's
not easy to get all that right now cloud
run is serverless so it can handle the
scaling part but the rest are still a
challenge
and your script handles all of that
including application secrets uh how is
that even possible
it's possible by the magic of
we'll probably have to make a few edits
to your settings.pi file
but i've been using it on my own web
apps for a bit now here let me run it
real quick to redeploy my application
and then we can integrate it into your
project
that sounds great uh
oh look there it goes
wow you and i just stood here like bumps
on a log while the script did everything
i know wasn't it great
i'll send you the link to the repository
and after you clone it we can walk
through it
okay uh i have the code up uh i've seen
a little terraform before but i'm not an
expert what am i looking at here
terraform is an open source
infrastructure is code tool that allows
for consistent declarative workflows to
manage large scale application
infrastructure
that's a bit of a mouthful but in short
it just means you get to write down what
servers your application needs and how
they should connect to each other and
terraform figures out how to make that a
reality
and it knows how to talk with google
cloud
it sure does looking up at the top of
the file the first block specifies a
dependency on the google cloud platform
bindings so with that terraform
downloads the necessary code to
translate everything that we write here
into google cloud api calls wow okay i'm
hooked can you walk me through this file
yeah so the next step make environment
variables locally accessible to your
terraform workflow you can hard code
anything that's fixed to via default
values and then leave the rest to be
passed in from the command line okay
that makes sense and what does the
script do next if you've ever configured
a new gcp project by hand in the web
console you've encountered the process
of activating specific service apis so
this next part looks ahead of the
complete set of service apis it will
require and turns them all on
we'll also want to set up a custom
service account to run our cloud run
service the default service account has
access to do a lot of things so i
usually create my own service account
and specifically set what it can and
cannot do
i love that this script even captures
the principle of least privilege
always
now the next step takes some time to
complete the first time you run this
configuration because it initializes an
entire cloud sql postgres instance
this section looks like it does a lot of
heavy lifting
i see the creation of a cloud sql
instance let's say a user and a specific
password
but how do we get that password into our
code uh hold on to that thought because
it is coming soon but first there's a
section that sets up the final project
specific values we have our admin user's
password and a google cloud storage
bucket to host our static and media
files
oh neat i like that terraform generates
these secrets so they never exist in
plain text yeah exactly and now the
terraform has generated everything
sensitive we can prepare to securely get
all of that information into our django
settings
okay that one is a little dense can you
walk me through it craig
absolutely this block uses a simple
template which i'll send you to create
an environment variable file with our
database credentials secret key and
storage bucket
later we'll make an edit to your
settings.pi file to actually read in
those values perfect because i have
flagged some to do's in my settings file
for each of those things uh what's next
here
so far we've generated values for a few
sensitive pieces of our app but
terraform has yet to actually share that
information with anyone so this part
creates a new entry in secret manager
and gives access to the necessary
service accounts
i see this creating new secrets but have
our secret values been uploaded to
secret manager yet ah yes good eye if
our terraform manifest ended here we
would in fact have some empty and pretty
useless entries in secret manager but
that's where this next part comes in to
gather up all of the values we care
about and populate those secrets ah and
i'm guessing that our django app will
then need to access these secrets during
startup
you're really quite a good guesser
martin has anyone ever told you that
oh shucks
so this is where that template file
comes in because the structure of the
secrets we have uploaded isn't just the
values awkwardly placed in the text file
but instead of valid environment
variables file that our application can
source thus allowing your django code to
pull those values right out of the
environment
wow terraforms thought of everything
and now we're getting to the cloud run
service definition
indeed it's taken a lot to get here but
the terraform manifest is now finally
ready to define our actual cloud run
service
i also see another i am setting there
yeah there's always more iem settings
and the google cloud console there's a
check box that says make this service
public in the g called cli it's the dash
dash allow dash on authenticated flag in
short these two just open up our service
to the entire internet which is of
course what we want
and speaking of policy uh looks like
you're also setting service permissions
and is that a for loop
yeah it is terraform allows you to
perform actions against a list of values
in this case we're giving both cloud
build and our actual django service
account access to cloud run and to cloud
sql
but why does cloud build need access to
the database
oh that's a good question
as most django developers know some of
your deployments involve schema
migrations that must be applied running
manage.pi migrant the only problem is
cloud run has nowhere to run that sort
of one-off command so to solve this i've
set up a series of steps in the cloud
build migrate.yaml script to run against
our container image one of these is the
famous migrate command and thus cloud
build will also require access to the
database
so is that your continuous delivery
configuration
yeah it is uh and you can run this
manually or as part of a deployment to
automatically run the steps that you
need to migrate your application or any
other commands that you need all right
uh there's one last part of the
terraform script that we haven't covered
uh these output parts here what are they
those are values that terraform will
display once it's finished applying
everything and these are the useful
values that we need our service url and
our super user password
of course we've defined our password as
being sensitive so it will only output
that if we explicitly ask for it we
could get those values by running gcloud
commands against cloud run and secret
manager but this saves some time
wow this is also
declarative
yeah that's the point terraform allows
you to capture your entire deployment
process in one declarative manifest and
it handles the rest
now all that mumbo jumbo about
consistent declarative infrastructure
really makes sense so with all this i
can go edit my settings.pi file now
sure can open up that file and we'll get
started editing
okay i'm in my settings.pi file and i'm
ready to grab my passwords from secret
manager
great i'm sending you a snippet now
which you can drop in at the top of your
file pretty much as is
this is hefty uh let's see
that read and function will read from a
local environment
plus a dot env file if i have one
but then we get to this try block let's
see
we attempt to use the google auth api to
load our default credentials in
production i know these are provided by
cloudron itself
if they're missing we must be doing
local development so it quietly fails
yep you're on the right track this setup
handles both production and local
development which is nice
ah and then if it sees we have a project
id
we use the secret manager api to get
those very same secrets we saved in
terraform manifest
and then with those values it loads them
into the environment as well
yeah precisely and instead of accessing
those variables via os dot environ like
you might be used to i do recommend
using the environ library to streamline
the process this sounds amazing
let me quickly edit my settings.pi file
in the other locations
to read in all of our secret values
first i'll update my secret key
then i'll let the environment package
handle all of my database settings
and lastly i'll read in the correct
static files bucket
okay so
craig you're telling me that if i run
this script now it will deploy my app
this task that i usually spend an entire
day suffering through will be just
done
almost open up that read me and you'll
see a few extra commands we have to run
the first time we deploy our project
okay
opening it now
all right i'm setting the project id
variable and activating it with the
gcloud cli
i'm already authenticated with my
project otherwise i would need to run
gcloud of application default login
enabling a few base services i see
i imagine this simplified the terraform
manifest in some way
uh next up is gcloud builds submit
i know this one it actually reads my
docker file and uploads the resulting
image to google container
registry oh and here we go
terraform in it
and terraform apply
whoa
look at it go things are moving pretty
fast
except
oh yeah you said the database would take
a while to initialize
yeah while that's working want to see
something neat
open up this project in the google cloud
console and you'll see this database
initializing exactly as if you've just
gone through the create cloud sql
instance wizard
oh
right
look at that database being created
like you said this can take a while uh
see you back here in five minutes
sounds good
all right uh the terraform script
finished successfully
and look uh just like you said it's
printed my cloud run services url
but first i have one more first
deployment command to run
yep but you'll actually run this command
anytime you deploy a change that alters
your static files or your database
schema
and now the last step we output the url
and check that it worked
oh my gosh i can hardly believe it
pretty neat eh yeah and now let me show
you something else cool run terraform
apply again uh but craig i don't need
two instances of my app deployed
no of course not but trust me run the
command again and see what happens well
you've never led me wrong before so here
we go
see
it detected that everything you declared
already exists so the whole process did
nothing
and now moving forward you can run that
command whenever you want and each pass
it will only do something if you've just
changed the terraform manifest
craig i honestly can't believe it with
this terraform script i can deploy my
entire django app to cloudrun in no time
this usually eats up my entire saturday
happy to help martin i would say maybe
next time as a thank you or playing
catan you can not play such hardball
with me when i propose resource trades
you can't just expect me to offer you
buy one get one on my lumber whenever
you need it
[Music]